Hi.
In this problem, we're going
to practice setting up a
Markov chain by going fishing in
this lake, which has n fish
in it, some of which
are green.
And the rest of the
fish are blue.
So, what we do is, every day
we go to this lake, and we
catch exactly 1 fish.
And all the fish are equally
likely to be
the 1 that's caught.
Now, if we catch a green fish,
we paint it blue, and we throw
back into the lake.
And if we catch a blue fish, we
just keep it blue, and we
also throw it back.
Now, what we're interested in
modeling is, how does this
lake evolve over time?
And specifically what we're
interested in is the number of
green fish that are
left in the lake.
So, let's let Gi be the event
that there are i green fish
left in the lake.
And we want to know, how does
Gi evolve over time?
Now, one thing that we've
learned that we can use to
model this is a Markov chain.
But before we can use it, we
need to make sure that this
actually satisfies the
Markov property.
Now, recall that the Markov
property essentially says
that, given the current state of
the system, that's all you
need in order to predict
the future states.
So, any past history of the
previous states that it was
in, that's all irrelevant.
All you need is the
current state.
Now, in the context of this
particular problem, what that
means is that if I tell you that
there are 10 green fish
left, that's all the information
you need in order
to predict how many fish
there will be tomorrow.
So, why is that?
Well, it's because what
influences the number of green
fish that are left?
What influences it is which
fish you catch because,
depending on which fish you
catch, you may paint the green
fish blue, in which case the
number of green fish decrease.
But what affects which
fish you catch?
Well, that probability is
dictated solely based on just
the number of green fish in
the lake right now, today.
So, it doesn't matter that there
were 20 fish yesterday.
All that matters is how many
green fish there are in the
lake today.
And so, because of that
argument, the
number of green fish--
this does satisfy the Markov
property, so we can use this
and model it as a
Markov chain.
So, like we alluded to just now,
the key dynamic that we
need to look at is, how
does the number
of green fish change?
And if we look at it, we notice
that after each day,
the number of green fish can
only have two possible
transitions.
One possible transition is that
it goes down by exactly
1, which happens if you happen
to catch a green fish and
paint it blue.
So, that green fish is no longer
green, so the number of
green fish goes down by 1.
The other possible transition
is that Gi doesn't change
because you caught a
blue fish that day.
So, all the green fish
are still green.
So, now given that, let's see
if we can come up with a
Markov chain.
So, the first thing we've done
is we've written down all the
different states, right?
So, this represents the
number of green
fish left in the lake.
So, there could be 0 green fish
left, 1 green fish, all
the way through n, which means
that every single fish in the
lake is green.
Now, we have the states.
What we need to do now is to
fill in the transition
probabilities, which
are the Pij's.
And remember, the Pij is the
probability of transitioning
from state i to state j in
the next transition.
So, what that means in this
context is, what's the
probability that there will be
j green fish tomorrow given
that there are i green
fish today?
Now, if we go back to our
earlier argument, we see that
for any given i, you can
only transition to
two possible j's.
One of them is you stay at i
because the number of green
fish doesn't change because
you caught a blue fish.
And the other is that you'd
go from i to i minus 1.
The number of green fish
decreases by 1.
Now, what we need to do now
is fill in what those
probabilities are.
So, if j equals i, meaning that
the number of green fish
doesn't change, well, what's the
probability that you have
the same number of green fish
tomorrow as you do today?
Well, if you have i green fish
today, that happens if you
catch 1 of the n minus
i blue fish.
So, what's the probability
of catching one of the n
minus i blue fish?
Well, it's n minus i over n.
Now, the other possible
transition is you go from a i
to j equals i minus 1,
so i goes down by 1.
And that happens when you
catch a green fish.
So, given that there are i
green fish, what's the
probability that you
catch 1 of those?
Well, it's going to be i/n.
And finally, every other
transition has 0 probability.
All right.
So, now we can add those
transitions on
to our Markov chain.
So, for example,
we have these.
So, let's look at this
general case i.
So, if you're state i, you
have i green fish left.
You will transition to i minus
1 green fish left if that day
you caught a green fish.
And we said that that
probability is i/n.
And the self transition
probability is you caught a
blue fish that day, so you still
stay a i green fish.
And that probability, we said,
was n minus i over n.
All right.
Now, it's helpful to verify
that this formula works by
looking at some cases where it's
intuitive to calculate
what these probabilities
should be.
So, let's look at state n.
That is the state where
every single fish
in the lake is green.
So, if ever single fish in the
lake is green, then no matter
what fish you catch, it's
going to be green.
And you're going to paint it
blue and return it, so you're
guaranteed to go down to
n minus 1 green fish.
And so, this transition
probability down to n minus 1
is guaranteed to be 1.
And so, the self transition
probability has to be 0.
Now, let's go back to our
formula and verify that
actually gives us
the right value.
So, if i is n, then there's
only these transition
probabilities.
So, if i is n, then the
transition probability to j,
for j is also n, is n minus
n over n, which is 0.
And that's exactly
what we said.
We argued that the
self transition
probability should be 0.
And also, if i is in, the
probability of transitioning
to n minus 1 should be
n over n, which is 1.
And that's exactly what
we argued here.
So, it seems like these
transition probabilities do
make sense.
And if we wanted to, we could
fill in the rest of these.
So, for example, this would be
2/n, 1/n, n minus 1 over n, n
minus 2 over n.
And now, let's also consider
the case of state 0, which
means that every single
fish is blue.
There are 0 green fish left.
Well, if that's the case, then
what's the probability of
staying at 0?
Well, that's n minus 0 over
n is 1, all right?
So, the self transition
probability is 1.
And that makes sense because
if you have 0 green fish,
there's no way to generate more
green fish because you
don't paint blue fish green.
And so, you're going to stay
at 0 green fish forever.
All right.
So, we've characterized the
entire Markov chain now.
And so, now let's just
answer some simple
questions about this.
So, the problem asks us to
identify, what are the
recurrent and transient
states?
So, remember that recurrent
state means that if you start
out at that state, no matter
where you go, what other
states you end up at, there is
some positive probability path
that will take you back to
your original state.
And if you're not recurrent,
then you're transient, which
means that if you're transient,
if you start out at
the transient state, there is
some other state that you can
go to, from which there's no
way to come back to the
original transient state.
All right.
So, now let's look at this and
see which states are recurrent
and which are transient.
And we can fill this in more.
And if we look at it, let's
look at state n.
Well, we're guaranteed
to go from state n to
state n minus 1.
And once we're in state n minus
1, there's no way for us
to go back to state
n because we can't
generate more green fish.
And so, n is transient.
And similarly, we can use the
same argument to show that
everything from 1 through n,
all of these states, are
transient for the same reason
because there's no way to
generate more green fish.
And so, the chain can
only stay at a given
state or go down 1.
And so, it always goes down.
It can only go left, and
it can never go right.
So, once you leave a certain
state, there's
no way to come back.
And so, states 1 through
n are all transient.
And 0 the only recurrent state
because, well, the only place
you go from 0 is itself.
So, you always stay at 0.
And in fact, 0 is not only
recurrent, it's absorbing
because every single other
state, no matter where you
start out at, you will
always end up at 0.
So, this was just an
example of how to
set up a Markov chain.
You just think about the actual
dynamics of what's
going on and make sure that it
satisfies the Markov property.
Then, figure out what all the
states are and calculate all
the transition probabilities.
And once you have that, you've
specified your Markov chain.